الى حفيد حفيدي سلام كيف حال شعب اسرائيل
هل يوجد شيء اسمه اسرائيل تحذير خطر في
صحيفه يدعو تحرنوت من الكاتب
بن عامي الذي كتب رساله تخيليه اكد فيها
ان الحرب الاهليه في اسرائيل اقرب من اي
وقت مضى وجهه نظر هي المسيطره في اسرائيل
حاليا ورئيس معهد سياسه الشعب
اليهوديا ساره على نفس الخط اسرائيل اليوم
اقرب الى الحرب الاهليه مقارنه بالوقت
الذي اعقب مقتل اسحاق رابين عام
1995 السؤال هل ما يحدث في اسرائيل هو
وليد اللحظه يجيب بمايكل الكاتب في
صحيفتها ما يحدث اليوم ما هو الا تتويج 55
عاما من الادمان على الشر والنهب
والاستبداد والعنف التحذير من اندلاع حرب
اهليه امتدا الى عدد من كبار الضباط بعضهم
في الخدمه وبعضهم الاخر في الاحتياط تكتمل
التحذيرات لرئيس البلاد
اريد ان اخبركم بشيء من القلب في هذه
الاسابيع قابلت الاف المواطنين افضل
مواطني البلد وطنيين حقيقيين من جميع
جوانب النزاع في اسوا كوابيس لم اكن اعتقد
انني ساسمع كلمات من هذه القبيل كلمات
مخيفه حقا يقول البعض من يعتقد ان حربا
حقيقي بين الاشقاء هي حد لن نصل اليه لا
يعرف شيئا